if I want the young people to understand
how to manage the failure if you want to
be innovators I am going to give you
what type of what type of characteristic
you must have see I have a feeling
whenever I do something I feel happy you
you want me you not your memory else by
breaking their limits of their
imagination they change they change the
world creativity leads to think when he
enters the classroom my teacher I see
radiation of purity of life leader
should work with integrity and succeed
with integrity so how did you become so
great how did I become so great that's a
question when there is order of the
nation there is peace in the world
he was the 11th President of India from
2002 to 2007 a career scientist turned
politician he studied physics and
aerospace engineer he was intimately
involved in Indian civilian space
program and missile defense systems is
APJ Abdul Kalam and here are his top 10
rules for success we should know how to
handle the not only how to handle
success how to handle the failures
particularly you are in the management
environment we were turn is I want the
young people to understand how to manage
the failure because any task you do you
have to come across problem problem
should not become the captain of the
individual or a project chief and the
project chief should become the captain
of the problems and defeat the problem
and succeed if you want with discoverers
if you want the innovators I am going to
give you what type of what type of
characteristic you must have the
invention and discoveries have Y
emanated from creativeminds that have
been constantly working and amazing the
out of the telephone he was amazing the
outcome you making the outcome in the
mind with the amazing and constant gear
for
all the forces of the universe work for
that inspired mind
thereby leading to invention discoveries
see I have a feeling whenever I do
something I feel happy you see this is
you trying and that whatever you may
have knowledge you hope sometimes
bettering economy you may have better
better baby sometime you can have a kind
words you can have so if you use and
make somebody's life happy that you are
giving and his or her life is a happy
that's a better best thing a human being
getting off that then you'll get a card
with conflict free world I learned what
did I learn from the youth of 11 million
people I learnt the ovary youth wants to
be unique every youth wants to be unique
that is you you were you taught to be
unique that is you but the world around
that around you is doing it best day and
night to make you just be everybody else
now now the question whether you want to
be you are everybody else you you want
to be you
not everybody else now
if the push be like everybody else
is convenient and the first class but
not satisfying in the long vision the
chalak therefore my young friends is
that you have to fight the hardest
battle you have to fight the hardest
battle which any human being can ever
imagine to fight and never stop fighting
until you arrive at your destiny you
history has proven history has proven
that those who dare to imagine the
impossible are the ones who break all
the human limitations in every field of
human endeavor whether science medicine
sports or technology the names of the
people just now I listed some of the
names the names of the people he making
the impossible or engraved in our
history by breaking the limits of their
imagination by breaking their limits of
their imagination a change they change
the world
you take CV Raman you take Newton you
take a Einstein you take Chandrashekar
thereby breaking the limits of their
imaging imagination they change the
world learning learning use creativity
creativity leads to thinking thinking
provides knowledge knowledge makes you
great you have many accomplishments
you've written books you've served as
president you're an aerospace engineer
you've been a professor but you say the
title you like best is the title of
teacher why is that you know I had I had
a teacher
whenever say young boy ten years boy
what am the second world war going on at
that time I used to see in my class
fifth class teacher in science teacher
he say mister Subramanya
he entered to the classroom and abused
to see the radiation of knowledge from
him radius of knowledge from him when he
enters the classroom my teacher I see a
radiation of purity of life and he's the
way he taught I my dream of God shaped
what should be my way of life he is the
person the teacher gave me the vision of
my life when I was a young fellow now a
teacher has got the fantastic
opportunity to grow minds to enrich the
minds and you that dreams to the young
people and nurture the dreams with them
and they would become a great human
being
sometime they will become better than
you but better than the teacher so that
happens you to have and also the teacher
like what I am doing I am a professor I
can also do the research young
researchers I will be work with me
that's a great pressure when they get
the PhD you've reaction of the leader
should be transparent you know what I
mean you say you're very that is leader
should work with integrity and succeed
with the next leader should work with
integrity and succeed when that active
and I believe president since you asked
the question has to be continuously in
touch with the people Rashtrapati Bhawan
where eyes I was there became a people
small instructor for the women it
becomes people's power and also I travel
in too-tall state cutting across Hill
deserts and see I was in touch with
millions and millions of people so how
did you become so great
how do they become so great that's a
question well which classier shoddy what
what's your dream in life how do I
become a single single is this on your
car navigation enemies enemies well I
don't know how big you know if they're
related terms so I personally believe
you Basava dream say you must I must
have a dream I'm a so a dream I must
continuously acquire knowledge
continuously acquire knowledge hard work
hard work and perseverance one should
not be of I wanna not afraid of problems
that you will be successful okay as you
say in India where there is
righteousness in the heart where there
is righteousness in the heart there is
beauty in the character when there is
beauty in the character there is harmony
in the home when there is harmony in the
home there is harmony where there is an
order in the nation when there is order
of the nation there is peace in the
world
mr. president Abdul Kalam in the name of
the European Parliament I want to thank
you for this important and inspiring
speech this was one of the most
extraordinary speeches we have ever
heard from a statesman scientist and
poet this is unique all the best to this
great nation India all the best to our
cooperation between the great nation
India and the European Union all the
best mr. president thank you so much for
watching we made this video because
ravichandran stood once again if you
have a famous entrepreneur that you want
to profile please leave it below I'd
also love to know which of the top 10
rules that we mentioned today meant the
most to you and the biggest impact leave
in the comments will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching to
believe and we'll see you soon